.
>> DO YOU WANT HIM REMOVED?
>> NO.
[LAUGHS]
>> Greg: WOW JUST HOURS AGO
JOE BIDEN CLAIMING JUST WHAT YOU
JUST HEARD HIM SAY IT WAS
ACTUALLY TRUE.
>> NOT WANTING ANYTHING BACK,
THE FACT OF THE MATTER I WAS
EXPRESSING THE OUTRAGE I FELT TO
HELP VLADIMIR PUTIN IS DEALING
WITH THE ACTION OF THIS MAN.
THE IDEA THAT HE IS IN A NEW
SUMMING OUTRAGEOUS BECAUSE I
CALLED HIM FOR WHAT HE WAS AND
WHAT HE IS DOING I THINK JUST
NOT RATIONAL.
NOBODY BELIEVES IN A TAKEDOWN
FROM OUTSIDE WHILE TAKING DOWN
VLADIMIR PUTIN, NO ONE BELIEVES
THAT.
>> Greg: OKAY JUDGE IT'S OUR
FAULT.
WE DIDN'T HEAR ANY OF THAT OTHER
STUFF WE JUST HEARD HIM SAY HE
CANNOT REMAIN IN POWER SO THAT'S
ON US OF COURSE HE AND MEAN IT.
>> Jeanine: HE KNOWS THAT HE'S
GONNA DITHER AND BLATHER INTO
WORLD WAR III.
EVERYTHING HE SAYS.
HE IS IN A CORNER RIGHT NOW,
YOU'RE IN A CORNER OF THE
QUESTION IS WHAT IS
VLADIMIR PUTIN TO DO NEXT?
HE'S TO DENTURE IT.
BUT I WANT TO KNOW IS WHAT HE
TALKED OF THE TRIPS A FEW DAYS
AGO YOU'LL SEE WHEN YOU GO IN
WITH UKRAINIAN SOLDIERS ALIKE.
EVERYTHING HE SAYS SOMEONE COMES
BACK AND THEY CLEAN IT UP.
WHAT I WANT TO KNOW IS THE
QUESTION THAT NO ONE ASKED AND
THAT IS WHO IS SHOWING THE ORDER
TO CLEAN IT UP, ASIDE FROM THIS
THING THAT CAN GET US IN THE WAR
IN THREE SECONDS BECAUSE OF
VLADIMIR PUTIN SHOULD BE
OUTRAGED AND PROBABLY IS.
THE QUESTION REALLY IS WHEN IT
RELATES TO CDC, WHEN IT RELATES
TO THE PENTAGON, WHO COMES AND
IT'S IS ALL RIGHT EVERYONE WE
HAVE TO WALK THAT STATEMENT
BACK?
WHO IS IN CHARGE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE?
WHO IS THE PRESIDENT?
[LAUGHS]
YOU KNOW IS NOT.
IT'S A VERY DANGEROUS TIME FOR
AMERICA AND A LOT OF AMERICANS
DON'T BELIEVE HE IS EQUIPPED TO
HANDLE THIS.
>> Greg: IVAN USES ANALOGY IN
A WHILE.
THE PRESIDENT IS LIKE A
CONTESTANT ON LET'S MAKE A DEAL
AND TURNS ON THE GUARANTEED CASH
JUST WANT TO KNOW WHAT'S BEHIND
DOOR NUMBER THREE AND SO AS I
GET 25-YEAR-OLD DONKEY TIED TO A
ROCKING CHAIR, HE NEVER MAKES
THE RIGHT DECISION.
>> Dana: SHE MIGHT'VE HAD A
BETTER TRIP TO EUROPE.
BOBBY SAID NARROW HEY, I DON'T
LOOK NOW.
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN HE LOBBY
WILL THINK HE GAVE A GREAT
SPEECH AND HE GIVES A SPEECH IN
THE AD AD-LIBS THE NINE WORDS
ASK A VERY GOOD QUESTION, WHO
DECIDED TO WALK IT BACK?
IS IMMEDIATELY ON MY GOT A CAN
BELIEVE HE SAID THAT.
HE THINK THAT THIS IS GOING TO
HAPPEN SO THAT'S WHY HE'S BEEN
USING IT AS AN EXCUSE THAT
YOU'RE SO PROVOCATIVE AND THAT
HAS BEEN OUR POLICY.
ELSE ON THE PRESIDENT SAYS THAT
AND THEN WHITE HOUSE STAFFERS
ANONYMOUS ON BACKGROUND TO
"THE WASHINGTON POST" YET HE
REALLY SCREWED UP THERE.
THEN YOU HAVE HIM TODAY SAYING
NO WHEN I MET WAS THIS.
HE COULD'VE DONE THAT ON THE
PLANE.
WHAT I WOULD'VE DONE WAS THAT WE
HAVE A PROBLEM SIR THIS IS WHAT
I HEARD YOU SAY IS THAT WHAT YOU
MEANT?
>> HIM TO BRING THE REPORTERS IN
THE CONFERENCE ROOM YOU CAN DO
ON THE RECORD FOR CLARIFICATION
WHATEVER THEY WANT CALL TO HIM
AND PUT THIS TO BED THAT NIGHT
AND SAID THEY WAIT THREE DAYS
THEY ALWAYS DO THIS.
TILDE SOLIDIFY PEOPLE'S MINE AND
ALL PEOPLE ARE EVEN MORE
CONFUSED.
>> DO YOU THINK THIS ENERGIZE
POLLUTANT AND HIS SUPPORTERS
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO BELIEVE
THAT IT'S ABOUT DECAPITATION,
GETTING VITAMIN FOOD NOW.
SO THIS IS VALIDATION.
>> THAT'S WHY SO FANTASTICALLY
DANGEROUS.
WHAT IT DOES IT BRING SOME
TOGETHER WITH HIS PEOPLE BECAUSE
HE'S BEEN TRY TO SELL THE
MESSAGE THAT THE AMERICANS IN
THE WEST WANT TO BASICALLY TAKE
US OVER.
WHAT MORE EVIDENCE DO THEY NEED
NOW THAN THE PRESIDENT OF
UNITED STATES ON THE RECORD ON
CAMERA IN FRONT OF THE WORLD'S
MEDIA REPRESENTING NATO.
THAT'S WHAT HE SAID WE HEARD HIM
SAY IT.
I SEE THEM WALKING BACK ON THE
WALK BACKS.
I CAN REMEMBER THE LAST TIME I
SAW A WORLD LEADER WHO TAKES
TIME TODAY TO WALK BACK THE
REPEATED WALK BACKS.
THE MINOR GAPS WHICH BY THE WAY
PROBABLY GAVE THE VLADIMIR PUTIN
IS WEALTHY AFGHANISTAN THE
AFGHANISTAN FIASCO THE
ENCOURAGEMENT HE NEEDED TO GO
INTO UKRAINE.
THE CHEMICAL WEAPONS RESPOND IN
KIND.
THAT MEANS USE CHEMICAL WEAPONS.
THAT HAD TO BE WALKED BACK TO
GROUND FORCES YES LIKE YOU
MENTIONED.
THAT'S FOUR TIMES, THREE IN THE
LAST WEEK WHEN THE PRESIDENT OF
UNITED STATES SAYS SOMETHING
THAT IS THAT'S NOT WHAT HE SAID
EVEN THOUGH THAT'S WHAT WE JUST
HEARD HIM SAY IT.
AND I WOULD COMES UP TO LOOK
DOWN THE BARREL OF THE CAMERA WE
DIDN'T WALK ANYTHING BACK SO NOT
ONLY DID YOU NOT TO ME SAY THE
ORIGINAL THING THE WALK BACK
ABOUT WHAT I SAID ORIGINALLY
THEY DIDN'T EXIST EITHER.
SHOULD BE WALKED BACK ANYWAY
[LAUGHS]
AND THE FOLLOW ANY OF THAT
YOU'RE A BETTER MAN THAN ME.
WHAT A FINE ALSO ABOUT THIS
WHICH IS REALLY UNSETTLING IS
THE DESPERATE WAYS THAT THE
DEMOCRATS AND MANY OF THE QUITE
LIBERAL SKEWED MAINSTREAM MEDIA
GO OUT OF THEIR WAY TO TRYING TO
FEND THIS.
WHAT ARE THE WAY TO TRY TO
PORTRAY THIS AS COMMANDING
LEADERSHIP WHEN THE POLLS AS WE
JUST HEARD ARE CRASHING TO NEW
LOWS WHEN CONFIDENCE IN HIM AND
TRUST BECAUSE OF ALL THESE GAPS
IS COLLAPSING THEY HAVE TO GET A
GRIP OF THIS BECAUSE IF YOU
CAN'T TRUST A WORD THAT HE SAYS
MAYBE BECAUSE HE CAN'T EVEN
REMEMBER SAYING IT THEN THERE'S
A PROBLEM.
HE'S THE LEADER OF THE FREE
WORLD.
>> Greg: JESSE MAYBE THIS IS A
POSITIVE SPIN NOBODY REALLY
BELIEVES WHAT HE IS SAYING.
EVEN THE WORLD LEADERS THEY LOOK
AT THEM LIKE FORCE COMPASS
POINT.
>> Jesse: THEY USED A MOCK
RONALD REAGAN BECAUSE HE WAS AN
ACTOR.
NOT A TRADITIONAL RESUME
POLITICIAN.
BUT REAGAN WAS CONSIDERED THE
GREAT COMMUNICATOR BECAUSE HE
COULD GET THE SCRIPT, SHOW UP ON
TIME, AND DELIVER IT WITH GUSTO
AND PRECISION.
HE WAS A BAR ON THE SAME AGE AS
JOE BIDEN AS WHEN HE WAS
PRESIDENT WE DIDN'T HAVE
PROBLEMS LIKE THIS LIKE WERE
HAVING NOW.
RONALD REAGAN WOULD GET UP THERE
AND NAIL IT.
EVEN OFF PROMPTER HE WAS STEADY.
TO YOUR POINT, THE WHITE HOUSE
NEEDS AND INNERVATION BECAUSE
YOU CAN'T HAVE KAMALA HARRIS
COME AWAY WITH LESS CASH AFTER A
TRIP.
AND AS A JOURNALIST I CAN SAVE
THIS AMOUNT OF AM I JOURNALIST?
I SHOULDN'T PROBABLY SAY THAT.
>> Greg: YOU CROSS THE LINE
THEM ENOUGH TO SLAP YOU.
[LAUGHS]
>> Jesse: THE WHITE HOUSE
NEEDS TO MAKE SURE THAT
JOE BIDEN GOES UP THERE DELIVERS
THE SCRIPT ON TELEPROMPTER AND
WALKS OUT BECAUSE YOU CAN'T HAVE
US IN A PROXY WAR WITH RUSSIA
WITH HIM GOING OFF SCRIPT.
GIVING VLADIMIR PUTIN THE
PROPAGANDA AND YOUR DIVIDING
NATO.
THEY EITHER NEED TO SET ASIDE
LATER TIME AND AIR FORCE ONE TO
DRILL INTO HIS BRAIN THAT THIS
IS THE MESSAGE, THIS IS WHAT YOU
SAY AND HAVE THEM HAD A LITTLE
DISCIPLINE AND CONFIDENCE AND I
VOLUNTEER TO PAR